well in Syria a drone attack has been
carried out on a graduation ceremony in
a Military College it happened in the
city of homs the defense minister was
reportedly at the event Syrian State
television reported several people have
been killed and many more injured
families invited to the ceremony are
among the
casualties we're going to speak to our
correspondent now zenah hod who's
following this from neighboring Lebanon
and Z what more can you tell us about
this attack and and who might have been
behind
it well there is no doubt this was a
significant attack a major security
breach a blow to the Syrian regime it
has been years since Pro Assad forces
forces of the Syrian president Bashar
alassad have been targeted in such an
operation in the heart of government
controlled Terr teritory what we know
that this was a suicide drone attack
this is according to Syrian State media
there was a graduation ceremony which
was attended by dozens um if not
hundreds of people um parents uh
students as well as senior officers we
understand there have been casualties
deaths and injuries and that the defense
minister was present at this ceremony we
don't know if he was the Target but he
was present at the time and the Drone
from the pictures that we are seeing
shows that it hit near the area where
the senior officials were sitting so in
the heart of government control
territory we're getting we there has
been still no claim of
responsibility um but it seems that the
the Syrian regime is blaming the
opposition because just moments after uh
this attack uh their um planes started
to Target res presential areas in the
opposition controlled Enclave in the
north northwest of the country and we
are also getting reports that there have
been casualties as a result of those um
artillery shelling and air strikes now
who could be behind this the regime does
have enemies uh but the opposition the
front line is is quite far more than 100
kilometers from where this drone attack
took place
but we also know is that the regime has
enemies within um within the regime
itself security apparatuses and
divisions of the army they have clashed
in the past U there is of course a power
struggle within the the the the state um
the state structure
itself okay thank you so much for that
update that is anaha for us uh who's
following the story from Lebanon